بالمواساه اعتبرت مسوده بيان قمه العشرين
التي تعقد في جزيره بالي باندونيسيا ان
استخدام الاسلحه النوويه والتهديد بها غير
مقبول وجاء في المسوده ان معظم الاعضاء
يدينون بشده الحرف اوكرانيا دعينا الى
ضروره تمديد صفقه الحبوب الاوكرانيه
واضافت المسوده ان المجموعه تبدي انشغالها
بتاثير الحرب في اوكرانيا على الاقتصاد
العالمي وشهدت طبعا القمه تصريحات ناريه
بدلها كل من الرئيس الاوكراني مع وزير
الخارجيه الروسيه
[موسيقى]
استعاده مثل عمليه انزال نورماندي
ولا مصلحه نفسه
[موسيقى]
بانشاء محكمه خاصه لمحاكمه شخصيه روسيه
على خلفيه حرب الروسيه على اوكرانيا
الاتحاد الاوروبيا
[موسيقى]
لن نقبل باي صيغه سلام لا تضمن سحب روسيا
قواتها وتشكيلاتها المسلحه من بلادنا
[موسيقى]
جميع المشاكل في تسويه حول اوكرانيا هي من
جانبك يافا